be more articulate when you speak to the
children yes sir i will make better
mouth
wait so you heroically fought off three
guys and that puts you in a bad mood if
i did that i would literally write a
song about myself it would be like jake
the hero abs of steel
broken ribs and a million broken toes
weren't enough for you in retrospect
they were plenty yes
the worst part is olson got away that's
the worst part
you could have died man i wasn't hurt
that badly the doctor said all my
bleeding was internal that's where the
blood's supposed to be now this
turkmenistani dish is traditionally made
from an animal that's been so overfed it
can no longer stand
that's a dream everything is authentic i
even ordered the pressure cooker from
turkmenistan so you're on a terrorist
watch list now oh yeah homeland
security's been in my house yep now this
just needs to cook for another 11 hours
32 minutes and six
what the hell boyle you almost killed me
i'm not going out in a stool making
accident terry's gonna die saving the
president or terry's never gonna die why
would you keep this from me and why
would you lie about going to fencing
because he couldn't go
because he's injured i wasn't injured i
was lightly stabbed i'm sorry you were
stabbed lightly stabbed hello raymond
captain wunch good to see you
but if you're here who's guarding hades
i need someone to fill out a lineup will
you be scary terry oh i love being scary
terry he says what regulatory's thinking
this is taking too long
i'm gonna miss the farmer's market do
you understand me oh this got physical
very quickly this is adult stuff jake
be serious look i promise i won't tell
anyone all right my lips are sealed good
do i even weigh anything to you no
it's like holding a couple of grapes
how about some tunes
cool
merry-go-round music yeah john philip
sousa the skrillex of his day come on
people hit the dance floor have a good
time
why is no one having a good time i
specifically requested it i've made
promises to my superiors that i most
certainly cannot keep that's why i need
you idiots to work twice as hard no no
strike that four times as hard no no
strike that i need you morons to work
eight times harder than you've ever
worked and your entire
life
i'm having a heart attack
yeah i'm having a heart attack
get back to work
get a doctor
you two have been in this evidence
locker for hey
what nothing
nothing you were just making out with
peralta
there's that candy bar rapper i was
looking for
oh santiago what are you doing here so i
guess it is hoes before it chose with
you friend now i understand why nothing
gets done in this precinct the
detectives are too busy frenching with
each other you know what your little
honeymoon is over because as long as i'm
here you two are done and i'm gonna be
here a long long long long long long
long long
oh this is a heart attack this right
here this is a heart attack oh it's a
big
one go time boyle hold terry close the
blinds release the roaches alternately
he could win an illegal street race in
which my love is surprised oh my god
gina look roaches
ew charles kill them with whatever
cologne you're wearing oh i can't
they're moving too fast i can't kill
them it's pandemonium if i die turn my
tweets into a book
you better look cute in this picture no
one's gonna want you
do something with your damn paws whoa
whoa sarge relax
look i think you might be overreacting a
little to this prank and i should know
you probably won't believe this but
i was bullied in high school for being
too handsome i don't believe you you're
right it was for setting my crotch on
fire in shop class hurt like the dickens
point is hater's gone hate shake it off
taylor swift always right
raymond
madeline you won
go ahead and gloat you toad
thank you for this honor
deputy chief
oh
okay
you're welcome
lunch time is over boom did it had it
both ways no regrets are you supposed to
be babysitting gina doesn't need my help
she's over there dazzling some
psychologists my mother cried the day i
was born because she knew she would
never be better than me
[Applause]
literal chills it was number five number
five killed my brother oh my god i
forgot about that part if someone broke
into your apartment and you weren't cops
wouldn't you be scared
yes
depends
how many guns do i still have hidden
none do i stole my knife
nunchucks
axe
it was a hypothetical question i know
but i want to play it out do i solve my
throwing stars this is taking a strange
turn
fine
i'd be scared
we're on it
kind of woman doesn't have an ax
why are you acting this way something to
promise to my son you can't understand
cause you're not a father you never will
be hey yes i will quinn jake we're all
waiting what are we even arguing about
now it's about me saving christmas duh
oh damn it my pants are snagged
now you have to wait for backup no i
don't i'm gonna shimmy them off
[Music]
oh god the eye contact is the worst part
[Music]
i told you jake i'll do anything to perk
up my little man you've got to know how
gross that sounds in your underwear i
wanted to be back in the field because i
wanted to be the old me but
the truth is i'm not the old me yet
maybe i never will be
anyways i'm gonna go cry in the bathroom
peace out homies
gina's the one who set him free how was
i supposed to know there'd be
consequences for my action enough she's
worried about her motorcycle sitting
idle so she wants us to take it out once
a day here
i think you should do this you're more
the biker type i've seen you use a
toothpick in public motorcycles are
death machines i have three kids i'm not
risking it are you saying my life
matters less because i don't conform to
society's heteronormative child-centric
ideals are you really playing the gay
card right now yes queen
i tried to write a kind speech about her
last night and this is what came out
oh
it's like 20 pages long why is it in all
caps so i remember to yell it i know
just the thing to cheer you up once is
dead bagel bagel
fagel i've been asked to deliver a toast
here after the funeral a message of
hope this is what i have so far
pain
[Music]
that's it god said when once tried to
sneak past the gates into heaven it
ain't happening honey
hey everyone someone just volunteered to
be dj b day
here at the fun zone we live by one rule
when it's your birthday you are always
cool parents and kids are all the same
watch
as i do a dance
to your name
again
you